jacob reese mogg
you're right you don't need to visit the
north of ireland
to understand the border you need to
have lived here
when the border was no man's land
neither your land or my land
a ragged stretch of spike and because
you do not like to think it's a problem
does not mean it vanishes a trick of the
eye
a trump lie just because you have said
the problem
is imaginary does not disappear the
thread of reality
i used to assume that magical thinking
meant wide eyes
a vision that doesn't stop with the sky
create a view on old to make it new
but no sure someone from the eu accused
westminster of magical thinking
no assumptions anymore about what magic
is
there's a lot of chat about imagination
when people talk of the border the irish
one you know between the northern part
and the southern
part and what keeps them apart
stone or moss hard or
soft you hear these things through
airwaves and screen and wonder what they
mean
boris johnson took a notion that our
border was just like his
donegal derry
camden and islington what's the
difference
i won't break down the distance there
between reality
and creative thinking
[Music]
magical thinking an
imaginary problem a pragmatic extension
of a reality that already
exists the magic
formula of words has yet to materialize
now there's a collection of words fished
from a misty view of what connects
me and you they're not pagan hopes just
quotes politicians struggling to grasp
the ungrabbable we're knee-deep in
philosophy here
trapped in other people's boundaries yet
to me
it feels quite real roads that start
here
and then there somehow allowing a wound
to heal
it's counterintuitive that nothing to
see now is more real than what there was
then nothing to see means reality
sounds magical doesn't it this is what
magic
in the day-to-day looks like the spirit
of peace
in the normality nothing outward
as such no extra levity just a
gentleness
in the mundanity daily travel
across political lines work
school grocery shops
back again magic is the absence
sometimes
and there was magic too in 1998
a very good friday and all the years in
between to make the border disappear
there but not there a line of
imagination that needed imagination to
make it exist
while on scene
and war that vulture who makes human
lives carrion
tears the beauty of identity to pieces
feasts on death cares not about any
cause
it shrieked and screamed as its roosting
places were turned into wider spaces
nobody ever thought that dismantling the
barricades like a jigsaw
bit by bit was a temporary measure
we thought the concrete was broken down
old wood
burnt weapons beat into plows
we hoped by digging out old roots the
grass would grow
over lines drawn in war rooms
and even though we would all know when
we drove from one political sphere to
the next
we would know what the earth would not
and so maybe the stale tight air around
the sight of fear
and death and human plight would burst
instead allowing a flowing
a growing with time
none of us expected this would be swift
that overnight
tensions would lift no
we're not the types to put faith in
magicians but we'll want to believe in
magic
and this was a start beginning something
a road with no blocks clear paths
we didn't think it was illusion that
pieces of the jigsaw falling away before
our eyes
didn't stop existing after all instead
packed away in boxes labeled and ordered
for use at a future time
ready for reconstruction down the line
were the decisions on that day sacred
for both sides of the divide
or just things that made the process
move ahead
for them apparently there hasn't been a
hard border here since 1923
you'd have known that wasn't true toby
young if you'd been here to see
and no i wasn't alive either when lloyd
george called ireland
the irish question that was 1916.
it's strange that now it seems the
people in power and the people who write
about us
are calling it that again we've got
questions
but now we're the irish question
isn't identity something to do with
magic
the mystery of birth what we cleave to
in life
another imagination given credence by
ritual
grows from the soil planted in the earth
rooted in how we see
where are the stereotypes here when some
of us have irish passports
some british some of both
overreaching arlene foster said about
the words and documents that will
determine what and when
but does anything happen then unless you
reach
beyond two kingdoms
bound by imaginations
that's why the language woven through
negotiations has a mystical threat
those at the head cannot help themselves
but use
the power of identity infusing and
confusing
practicality
we live here and we're holding our
breath again
because we know that chance and hope
come in forms like steam
and smoke
you